很多东西他就是根深蒂固的，
我给他举一个例子，
有一个演员演美姐姐，
那个演员，
他有一次就说到过一个事儿，
说他一屁股做到了一个，
一般那个拍摄的设备嘛，
他都是一个金属的那个大盒子嘛，
对对对，
不允许女性做，
那男性就可以做，
而且它在这个圈子里的话，
它是一个就大家都那么认为，
但是你声想的话，
我们女性凭什么呢？
为什么说我们女性的胯下就是脏的，
为什么女性的月经期就是脏的，
为什么女性就生孩子，
就是误会的，
在我们看来啊，
我们现在是接受了教育，
接受了一些公平的这样一个思想，
在我们看来这多可笑的一件事儿，
但是这些东西她已经在老一辈人那里根深蒂固了，
我们改变不了，
我们唯一能做的是什么？
姐妹今天跟她聊，
认真聊我们唯一能做的时候，
当有一天我有了女儿，
我会告诉她不要有任何的羞耻，
我会告诉她女人的胯下，
女人的月经，
女人生孩子，
女人的内裤，
女人的内衣，
这些东西都不存在误秽的问题，
我会告诉她这些，
但是我依然会告诉她，
如果你进入了那个环境，
她们是老一辈人的思想，
那么在不损害我的利益的前提下，
我尽量就不要去破坏他们的所谓的那个规则，
就是不引发冲突，
就是这意思，
就像你现在如果他们认为说，
哎呀，
大年初一了，
女儿不能回来。
吃饭了，
尽管这个房子是我的，
但是我也懒得跟你吵，
我也懒得跟你闹，
我也懒得跟你说，
我有这个功夫的话，
我多挣钱去，
我多学一点儿挣钱的本事，
我有这功的话，
我多结交一点能带着我挣钱的朋友，
钱哪有功夫跟你们吵？
我们同为女性，
我们都经历过这些，
是不是？
包括我奶奶，
我的姑妈小的时候都是用各种规训，
女孩子不能够跨过男孩子的衣服，
不能坐在男孩子的床上，
不能怎么怎么样的，
如果说以后龙飞姐有这个福气，
我要是有一个女儿的话，
那我就会跟她聊这些话题，
就不管别人怎么规训你，
我们女孩子对我们自己的身体要有一个健康的认识，
我没有任何东西是污秽的，
没有任何东西是什么不洁的，
是什么带来霉运的，
没有我是健康的，
我是完整的，
我们也要教育我们的儿子，
是不是对待这些老的这种思想儿子呢？
也要有她自己的认知水平，
不要让我们的儿子被规训成那种觉得女人的胯下是羞耻的，
是带来霉运的，
是怎么怎么样的啊，
就这意思啊。